I'm having so much fun Nikki Bella and
Artem are celebrating love over the
weekend the two attended Val
Chmerkovskiy and Jenna Johnson's wedding
in Rancho Palos Verdes California both
Nikki and Artem are pals with the
newlyweds val was a pro on Dancing with
the Stars when Nikki was partnered with
our dome during season 25 I loved
meeting Artem and getting to know him
and spending time with him while Jenna
was a troop member that year Nikki took
to Instagram to share pics and videos of
the couple's big day including this clip
of her and her man riding in the car
together hey
[Music]
Nikki looked Gorge in a black strapless
dress with a high slit while Artem
rocked a maroon velvet blazer black
shirt and bowtie the two have been
spotted on dates together since December
2018 happiness like just fully being
happy and so that's what I really want
their time together was documented on
the most recent season of total Bellas
[Music]
the 35 year old pro wrestler called off
her engagement to John Cena last summer
but I just can't imagine my life without
you John I just can't imagine not
getting married and spending the rest of
my life to get there but in September
Nikki told ET she's enjoying this new
chapter in her life I feel like it I'm
at that age where I'm discovering who I
really am and what do I want out of life
and just like independence and I'm
enjoying I'm not gonna lie is it scary
and you have these moments of like what
am i doing and you have fear but I just
I kind of am liking the challenge and
that fear because it's just sports to
maybe out of my comfort zone and while
she and Artem have been spending lots of
time together yes we are dating yes who
spend the night at his house Nikki
recently revealed on her podcast that
they aren't exclusive
yeah we're dating okay there we go no
that's it we need details well look so
there's not a lot of speculation about
us but I'm still dating so so you and
Artem aren't serious but we're having
fun okay
he's showing me LA